bien sûr que tous ces gens qu'on perd on
est en pleine saison d'été et on est en
train de nous elles flinguées notre
saison à mon avis c'est une mission qui
est impossible pour contrôler tout le
monde ça c'est impossible
[Musique]
on sait de l'expérience de la culture
depuis le 21 juillet qui nous ont
enregistré nous perdre d'activité des
fréquentations de 70 % ou plus et au
bout d'un moment il vaut mieux rester
fermés que ouvrir et engager des frais
quand on n'a rien fait depuis cette
année on a été fermé on a souscrit à
toutes les mesures pour nous a demandé
d'appliquer et on continue encore un
finalement à piétiner notre activité
c'est le fruit de c'est avec ça qu'on
vit nous savait que ça convient
[Musique]
ben déjà déjà en fait dans la
restauration je peux vous dire depuis
trois-quatre mois en galère à trouver
des gens vraiment cette galère totale et
on donne des consignes à mes équipes de
contrôle est vraiment les clients à
l'entrée des restaurants
c'est notre responsabilité aujourd'hui
je souhaite adapter à cette décision là
à chaque fois j'ai réfléchi profondément
je vois que les choses qui sont très
compliqués à les gérer
quand on a intérêt de soixantaine de
personnes
[Musique]